while many fans couldn't really make
sense of jared leto's joker and suicide
squad there's no arguing against the
fact that the movie's clown prince of
crime had a really unique look
but now writer director david ayer has
confessed that he made a mistake with
the character's design
whether you love it or you hate it jared
leto's joker design makes an impression
from his pale white skin and bright
green hair to his eye catching tattoos
and silver teeth
he has a look that screams gangster
meets prankster
but was this stylized design really the
right approach
over two years after suicide squad's
theatrical run ayer has confessed that
he now considers one particular piece of
letto's joker design to be a total
mistake
the admission came about thanks to a fan
on twitter who asked ayer about the
joker's eye-catching forehead tattoo the
one that simply reads
damaged when asked what inspired that
particular bit of ink
ayer admitted that it was his idea and
he regrets it the director responded to
the query with a
maya culpa writing yes i have to fall on
that sword it was one step too far
even after owning up to what he now
feels was a bad move
ayer affirmed that he still generally
likes the tattoo at least in concept he
also gave some insight into his thought
process as to why the joker would have
such a statement scribbled across his
cranium
in a follow-up post ayer wrote in my
mind it was meant for batman after he
smashed
joker's teeth for killing jason todd
some people found it alienating
originality and faithfulness to the
canon are often at odds
batman and joker are my two favorite
characters ever
ayer offered a similar explanation for
the joker's damage tattoo around the
time suicide squad launched in theaters
saying that joker would have gotten the
tattoo while locked up in arkham asylum
after being scooped up by the dark
knight
as he told empire in august 2016 it's in
the asylum where joker would have done
the damage tattoo as a message to batman
saying
you've damaged me i was so beautiful
before and now you've destroyed my face
that's where the grill comes from as it
happens ayer has quite a few regrets
about the decisions he made with suicide
squad many of which come down to the
choices made about the joker
not only does ayer now wish he didn't
ink up the joker's forehead
he also regrets not making the character
the main bad guy of the movie's story
despite being heavily featured in the
movie's promotional materials
jared leto's joker only has about 10
total minutes of screen time in the
theatrical cut of suicide squad
far less than what was originally shot
for the super villain picture
even people who enjoyed the movie have
said that it could have been improved by
an increased focus on the evil jester
and some have approached ayer on twitter
with their thoughts in response to one
fan who wrote him a year after the
movie's release
ayers said believe me i agonize over
this
yes joker should have been the main bad
guy yeah
ayer has been expressing some
disappointment in the final cut of
suicide squad since shortly after the
film opened in theaters
in january 2017 the director penned a
lengthy post detailing what he wished
he'd done differently
then shared a screenshot of the note on
his twitter page in the post he wished
for a time machine to undo the errors he
feels he made
along with a determination to do better
next time as for what he'd do
differently he said
i'd make joker the main villain and
engineer a more grounded story i have to
take the good and bad and learn from it
i have to give the characters the
stories and plots they deserve next time
real talk as we know now he'd also do
away with that distracting tattoo
ayers self-criticism is refreshing but
he doesn't have to be so tormented
as divisive as suicide squad turned out
to be upon release the movie still
performed well enough for warner
brothers in dc to turn a massive profit
off of it
and despite the critical drubbing plenty
of fans still truly enjoyed the film
joker and all it can even be argued that
crafted the most
unforgettable version of the joker that
has yet to grace the screen
making a major impact on pop culture
despite the character's slight screen
time like the rest of suicide squad
ayers joker isn't necessarily a disaster
it's just
a little damaged